音樂
不好意思
我最近上那個電視台
然後就看到你的群組
在跟我打招呼
Hello
用詞很奇怪
他說跟你提供
成間的一個新聞
我想說這個用詞
不太像台灣會常用的
現在網路上詐騙
集團非常多
我只有提醒投資人
自己注意
因為真的太多了
也不是只有我啦
差不多老師大概你都會碰到
上達人秀的幾乎每一個都有
古於小哥阿格利
對 永年老師 諸老師
全部都有 都有詐騙
所以我只有希望大家自己小心
那至少我的 我可以提供大家
我的個性啦
就說你看到這個是不是我的
很容易變適 很容易怎麼變適
第一個 我不會再群組
你寫這麼多字
我相信我的群組的學生
你也不會貼這些詩題
對我很少發言
所以我發言一次
還有很多同學都認為
這真的是朱老師嗎
才會覺得你才是詐騙
對
所以你一看寫了一大篇
還真是文情並茂
一大堆的
但是最後叫你去買什麼股票的
你叫提高警察
是
那這個也是一樣
第二個特徵就是
你一看什麼懸鼓致富還免費的
他還把你的紅寫錯
對
那這樣子他就說不是我了嘛
對不對 可是照片是我
可是你看喔 你明明紅是這開寫錯
他還把我放這邊也
欸 笑相全
對啊對啊
所以大家注意喔
這個沒有這麼好的免費加入
免費加入你可以啦
但是進去以後
他只要叫你什麼買股票
那都不是我
我都不會叫你買股票
對
所以朱老師
從上課一開始的原則就定了
不帶盤不帶鈔
純粹教學
把這個魚肝教給你
那你就知道這個是真的還是假
而且看朱老師教學
不會在賴群組裡面
會在我們的節目裡面教學
或是實體開班授課
絕對不會在裡面教什麼東西
而且你看這簡體字嘛
簡密包而接字訊什麼
什麼壓力位反彈中期
這不是台灣會用的股票名詞
所以大家自己稍微分辨一下
分辨一下
真的 因为太多人
像我们最近有人来留言
说一个蔡兰族单亲妈妈
被谁骗 拜托拜托
大连秀的朋友
真的我们没有
老师成立这些群组
都不待进待出
还有我可以提供大家一个好方法
我相信现在每个人都有群组
要不然他也不会骗到你
你一定是有群组
那你是不是把这个图
接下来去问你其他群组的朋友
你只要接下来
問別人別人就會告訴你這張片
你就不會上當
你不要自己一個人在那邊悶得頭
就去家
對
好不好
好
歡迎收看今天的理財達人秀
大家最喜歡的標古在線等
剛剛花了一點時間
因為最近被炸片的朋友越來越多
尤其達人秀現在可能名聲很紅了
所有上過達人秀的
包括像朱老師
好多人以他們的名義
成立Taylor Gurren
成立賴群組
裡面你一進去他就叫你買股票
這樣記得達人秀的來賓們
絕對不會帶進帶出
他絕對不會在群組裡面
叫你買A買B買C甚至買港股
絕對不可能
大家的血汗錢一定要守好
今天再一次的強調
那當然你要看最貨真價實
有料的教學就要鎖定標股在現等
今天要教大家兩個造化
也常常在看的指標什麼
就是你會記得
每次大盤在講的時候就會告訴你
今天留了一個常常的上影線
上影線好像就是一個不好的代表
可是是這樣嗎
然後有時候會告訴你
今天有一個下影線
買盤的力道很強
但是有下影線就代表會漲嗎
今天朱老師要用一堂課的時間
教你上下影線最正確的用法
我們先來看
其實不只造華愛用
很多的新聞報導也非常愛用
大家就會看到
例如說永縣邁壓
永縣邁壓
他就寫留下217點的上影線
在這邊好像上影線就是一個很恐怖的事情
好像盤中有一個高價尾盤沒有
好可怕喔
就是有人在賣
有人在賣
然後這邊長魚百點
然後收了一個長下影線
他還幫你註解
代表下檔空間有限
好像下影線就很不棒
對
看位置
等一下我們教學
那我再快速的講一下
例如加權指數
好像真的耶
你看有下影線往上漲
有下影線往上漲
有上影線往下跌
順口溜
我們大盤大概
大家印象還很深
因為時間還不久
各位記不記得這天跌300點拉上來
對啊
對 那天大家嚇死了
盤中撿股票都轉翻了
那天盤中殺300點
你股票大概已經殺光了
很多都跌到停板
對啊都嚇死了
可是你看他一拉上來
你就知道第二天有機會了
你就懊惱
盤中幹嘛賣應該要買
沒錯
所以你看第二天是往上的
一連長四五天
四個
今天才算休息一下
對
對不對
所以連續長了四天到五天
所以這個K線的變化
各位一定要了解
懂了以後
你就可以應付很多的變化
我應付
好那我今天特別來告訴
各位這兩根線
一般來說我們的上影線很長的話
這個叫避雷針
我們叫避雷針
等一下屋頂上會有的
這個比較低的
下影線比較長的叫吊輪線
吊輪線你看這是人頭
好
等一下我們今天就會很詳細的
介紹這兩組線
因為對你來說是非常有用
尤其是大盤在急漲
像最近不是船船谷都漲漲的
連殺四五根的對不對
很多都是
然後很多會開高走低
他走低就會留下這個上一線
就會留下這些訊號
那你大概獲利也很好
你要不要短線先跑一下
那這些訊號就會告訴你
尤其我們一直在教各位技術分析
那技術分析就是看K線的訊號
這背後有什麼原因
可能你事後才知道
你當天可能不知道
或者過個三五天才知道
所以但是我們看K線
就當天就可以知道
它可能的反應
好
先來看一下壁壘針
上引線
那股價上漲
最怕就看到這個上引線
這個好像一個長長的壁壘針
在上面
那是不是有雷要打下來
那有雷打你要不要跑
你要跑
好 那我們
壁壘還是引雷
雷會不會逼下來
那我們來看一下
一般來說
為什麼他會留一個長的上銀線
我們看當天就知道說
是不是盤中拉了很高
對 然後我就想
快漲停了 我去追
對 拉收盤的時候他就殺下來
所以這跟K線當天的交易的情形
他反映說
可能是又多 然後下殺
他給你拉上去大家追著買
買了以後他就
有人就主力拉高就出貨給你
那是不是就收到低檔
那我先解釋一下上影線基本上
這個上影線是實體棒的兩倍
兩倍以上
所以你就很清楚
這個比較長
也就是說這個大概占三分之二
這個占三分之一
那紅跟黑是一樣的
看法是一樣的
你這邊是紅的也一樣
那都代表當天拉高
然後有人去賣出來了
也就是拉高之後買盤不計了
因為賣壓太重
就一直疊一直疊這樣疊下來
好那出現的這個當然就是一個訊號
那我們要看一下位置
比如說這個位置是不是已經長了三四天
所以長了三四天
理想也知道在下面買的人
他有賺錢嘛
他有可能今天也會跑掉
因為拉高了就往下了嘛
他也會跑
那短線上可能這個
前面有壓力可能也會
有的時候這個也是會碰到壓力出現
那碰到壓力出現
就是這裡代表有麥芽
前面有人在解套了
有解套麥芽
那我們碰到了這種情形
你就要小心
第二天就容易下來
它就容易下來
那我們看幾個圖例
以實際的例子來看
對 你的印象就會比較深
那尤其是幾長
我一直講多頭的股票
連拉三天
而且後面都是長紅
對 各位你就看這個第一天
這個是多頭確認
然後一天兩天三天
第四天還拉
他還拉了一個高點
相當高
如果你用這個看
這個180
這已經拉到230了
所以這個短線獲利過高
而且今天又出現這個
那就表示有人在賣了
老師但是他也有一個下影線
對如果今天上下影線都有的話
是看長度嗎
對上影線越長
當然他的壓力就比較大
那相比線就是表示有人在下面買
可是你買的力道比較小
那我們怎麼分辨今天多空的力道
就是用收盤價
用收盤價
你看收盤價上面大概4分
5分之4都是賣的
下面只有5分之1是買的
所以當然賣壓很重
那你如果也在這買
今天是不是要考慮一下
因為你也賺錢啊
你也賺了這根長紅啊
對不對 那你就考慮一下
那主要就要看第二天
第二天如果不漲
當然他就會回來
可是如果你看好了
你已經想好了
明天要跌我就要賣
那我就跟大家講
執行力就很重要
所以你明天要賣
如果不賣你沒有賺錢
你一毛都沒有賺
還殺回來
所以看到這個訊號
在高檔的時候
最好先走一趟
對 最好先走
因為他急漲
急漲就很容易集結
所以我們看到
必雷針注意這幾個
第一個它就是漲多要下跌的訊號
所以這個是指上漲的時候
這個必雷針是在上面
尤其剛剛講極漲的時候
對極漲的時候
那第二個
如果這個必雷針又爆了一個量
那當然就表示今天
賣的人非常多
那各位一定也會問
也有人買啊
對啊 買賣都多啊
搞不好人家在換手啊
對啊
那可是你今天的量爆得很大
有人買有人賣
但是你收是收在下面
你上面是上你線嘛
那你收在下面啊
就已經比較弱了嗎
就賣壓比較重
買盤是退後來接的
就是一直往下退著接的
好 那多頭就準備停利了
就是你有獲利的啦
有的時候你強反彈也會這個情形
有人喜歡強反彈嘛
那你一下子急拉
那你很高興啊
強反彈就搶到了
可是上面一出現這個
你大概想反彈也要停歷了
要準備走了
這邊有講次日是不能下跌的
買賣都很多
如果隔天他很猛
他也在漲
可能我們可以稍微等等
對 好
那我們就來觀察幾張圖
各位就可以學會了
這也是連漲三天
這個很可怕
所以我們在教學也跟同學一直講
不要追第三天第四天
你追第三天第四天
你也沒有賺到錢
因為你很容易
你來這邊是不是
一 二 三 四
有沒有上你線
有
你就回來
他就會休息
所以第一個
不要去追這個急漲
尤其這個跳空跳空
你不要去追第三天
尤其是第四天
第四天最容易拉高就會下來
最容易出這個
上你線
第四天
這個出了以後
第二天各位看是不是就跌了
對
我這個隔日確認
那就真的不要再重挖了
你就趕快離開了
那後面就沒有機會了
你到這裡就疊停疊停
那邊有別的因素導致
但是這一段就很明確了
沒錯 就告訴你說
我們如果會技術分析
你又能夠反應得快的話
我記得我在上課有跟大家講
你完全照技術分析
你不會踩到地雷谷
如果這是一隻地雷谷
你到這裡已經跑不掉了
地雷谷都這樣
到這裡就一直疊了
你已經跑不掉了
那老師啊
我就在這邊
我要做空的話
我現在不賺寶了
做空因為這是多頭回檔
好 不能亂做
他還不是空頭
那還不是空頭
除非你能夠確認空頭在做
但至少你多擔不要被套租
好 不要套租
先獲利了結公
那我們來看一個比較複雜的圖
這個就有做空的可能了
因為它本身這個就空頭嘛
對
你看是不是空
長上引線 然後後面就過不去
其實這個都上引線
這一家很容易流上引線就對了
然後這裡也一樣 長上引線
然後就會往下
長上引線第二天
第二天一疊 它就會往下
那這個做空是因為這邊已經是空頭
是空頭趨勢
它已經空頭 尤其是有爆亮
我們剛才有講下面有爆亮
爆亮流上引線
爆亮流上引線 第二天不漲
它就容易疊
他就很容易跌
這比較特殊的例子
那我們就另外來看一下
多頭上漲出現超長的上銘線
這時候我們剛才有講
第二天不可以下跌
第二天下跌他就要回來了
那第二天出現爆亮紅K上漲
那你還可以再觀察一下
這剛剛趙華問的
搞不好隔天我也看過
不一定就會跌啊
搞不好很強啊
沒錯
所以我們就看一下第二天
那第二天如果他是紅K上漲
那你還可以觀察一下
好
那表示第二天又有人來買了
是不是等於有人在洗呢
對
後續突破上影線的高點
你才能夠確認
因為我們這邊出現的
長上影線我們剛剛有講
這邊賣壓嘛
所以它是壓力
那你要讓這支股票轉強
還要把這個上影線的高點突破
那換句話講
你如果今天賣掉了
廠商你現在你怕
你也賺到了
賺了三天你賣掉了
那第二天紅K
但是這個紅K你不能買
再等一天把廠商你先吞掉
要過高 那你就可以買了
那就表示這個叫換手
就是剛才趙華講
到底是出貨還是換手
那就看後面股價怎麼走
往下跌就出貨
往上攻過再攻就是換手
他就是換手
好
那我們你來舉個例子
原來有人流傳上癮
現在還可以活下來的
可以
這就是
哎呦這我們剛
這就是今天的
剛剛才推薦他的台尼
看這是不是1 2 3 4
第四天是不是就爆亮
是
爆了大量黑K流了上癮
因為他手盤在下面
這都要怪達人秀
達人秀推薦他以後
是在這邊推
隔天呢
開一個超高 幾乎漲停
所以我在這也一直跟大家講
因為我們在節目的時候
是固定的時間嘛
沒有辦法說今天剛好就是明天可以進場
所以我也跟大家講
為什麼要學這個線上等
因為線上等就是告訴你
有人告訴你這是股票很好喔
但是它不是你買的位置
你就忍耐一下
你不要馬上進去
都會回檔的啦
你馬上進去就被
當天至少嚇死了對不對
你買在高點就嚇死了
那你想說這下糟糕
明天要往下跌
那你就要停損
因為你在買在最後一天
我們講你進場的第一點
跌破你就要停損
以防萬一真的
這你爆了量就一直跌怎麼辦
像剛才那個跌停跌停跌停
對不對
第一個你不要在這裡買
股票好但你不要在這買
這個我一直跟大家教學講的
那第二個 你再手停水嘛
對不對 因為你昨天買了
今天之後 之後任命看
我任命一下了 真的跌 我就停水
今天開高喔 對
你就稍微的不要馬上賣
因為他開高盤 對
那你看收盤是不是把上影線過了 對
其實你昨天忍耐一下 你今天可以買
今天反而可以買
今天比昨天貴那一
今天
那是因為他今天長了
如果今天疊你就不會講了
可是朱老師你看
他還抱了一個大量
又一個上癮線 難道不危險嗎
沒有 今天的量一定要抱
因為你要比昨天的量大嘛
罰吃掉
你就是昨天所有的人
今天都來賺錢
所以昨天的人就沒套牢了
達林秀感謝大家的支持
不然的話他要套牢怎麼辦
因為這是今天發生的
一般人來講你大概不敢買
對 對不對
就像你講的這麼高
老實說第四根都不能買
怎麼還可以買第五根
這個好像沒道理對不對
那我跟你講的道理就是
因為你第四根的大量
被紅K給突破了
那這是壓力
壓力突破就會轉強
它就會轉強
好 我們來看這一張
鋼鐵骨 標骨
這一張你看這是多頭確認了
這邊是不是打了一個底
第二天第三天第四天
留個上雨線
可是還在攻呢
一對不對
可是這短線已經走了一波
大概也有10%
大概走這邊大概14 5%
那這樣子明天就有可能跌
對不對
那也許你想明天跌
讓我小賺一點我要跑了
第二天沒跌
可是你還不能買
因為你這個上雨線還沒過
所以你看這個還沒過 還沒長喔
因為你的上癮天還沒過
好 這個過囉
然後你買進去了
一天漲停 第二天漲停
那剛才趙華不是講
哇 這個這麼高總買
對啊
我第四根沒買 第五根沒買
買第六根了 這還是第六根
這個你不敢買
可是你買了兩根漲停板
這你就兩根漲停板
可是這兩根就來囉
這根就要掉人線了
就是有一個好長的下影線
這個我們就等一下講
那天鋼鐵是有點開低
然後走高鎖掌庭
沒錯
至少他鎖掌庭你不會賣嗎
因為你是鎖掌庭
鎖住了就算了
就
好
所以從這裡就看到
大量的長上影線要是過高
他就會轉牆
他就是再走一個短波段
這邊我們講三天是一個短波段
那你這裡又是一天兩天三天
所以它又是一個短波段
好 那大家大概知道這個所謂的
這個我們剛講的這個上影線
閉了一針
那剛好最後出現一個吊人線
我們就接著來講 下影線
我們就接著來講吊人線
下影線怎麼看呢
那就把剛才那個180度反一下
兩個小實體棒在上面
這個下影線是它的兩倍
那這個就代表這個是很長的下影線
那這個叫調人線
剛才我們講
碧雷針在上面
大家都比較能夠理解
因為有人在賣
沒錯
那所以也會跌
對啊
那這個不是有人在買嗎
對啊 為什麼一樣的結局
怎麼兩條就一樣
那我們去思考一件事
一個好多股票每天
不管是大漲小漲
他都在漲
那長的意思就是每天的多方都很強
都沒有人在賣
那請問今天的盤中是什麼現象
今天盤中有人在殺
有人一直殺一直殺
有人一直接一直接
對
對 有人殺下去囉
表示今天看到敵人
本來我每天都在攻
都沒有看到敵人
那我的部隊就一直往前推
對不對 就一直往前推
可是今天
不知道誰
今天敵軍出現
在對抗的時候我還被打退了
我真的還被打退了
暴露上效 敵軍很強
對 今天有敵軍了
那這個告訴你今天有空方出現
你是不是要預防明天
萬一空方還在 沒有被你打光
我有攻上來嘛
萬一空方明天再來
他就會下跌了
所以這個告訴你
你今天盤中有空方的力量出現
最近真的蠻多
很多
對岸軍機
對啊
飛來繞來繞去
OK
所以最後當然我們說要看收盤
如果收盤拉上去
就跟剛才的壁壘爭一樣
你在等明天看盤
隔天確認
明天是不是在殺
所以這個叫下殺的洗盤換手
還是主力出貨在右多
那怎麼樣來確認
就是明天就會告訴你
好
那我们这两根线
在我们的K线里面都归做变盘线
统一都叫变盘
因为变盘线很多
十几种
那这两个都叫变盘线
变盘线意思就是提醒你
明天可能变盘
变盘意思就是上涨变下跌
下跌变上涨
好不好
那在高档的话
那就是变盘就容易往下
高档的话两种线都比较容易往下
因为都叫变盘线
好 我們來看一下囉
這個就很清楚了
他在前一天就已經出現掉人線
也是殺下去拉上
好像有人在
支撐
有人撐嘛
但是盤中也有人在殺
有人在殺
那第二天又出現
因為我講看第二天
那第二天我一開高是不是很好
怎麼又有人在殺
怪怪的囉
對 又有人在殺
那殺了以後又收在最高點
那我就再看明天囉
明天好像就不死了
明天有殺下來喔
沒有人拉了
沒人拉了
沒人接了
對 沒有人拉了
所以這個股票就要跌了
他已經
其實這個有
這個有像主力
在盤中又多了兩天
他又你一定會買嘛
買了第二天你去殺
然後他一拉你又進去了
因為你看他又漲了
那你又在這裡買了
買了第三天其實有高點
還有高點主力在賣
這次他就不拉了
所以你就被套在這
因為這一檔說真的啦
從這樣已經漲一大段的
然後大家就會想說前面都沒賺到
後面好像有機會就想上去
看他好像噴出來了嘛
結果你又犯了一個錯誤
你又買在第二天第三天
你又買在高檔
不要買在這個高檔
這樣好不好
那你買了也沒關係
我常常講說
如果你懂得這些訊號
你能夠及時走掉
你也不至於這樣大賠嘛
你這一培10% 20%
你也不會大培嘛
所以我們學K線轉折就是
最快的一個訊號
它是第一手資料
那我們說趨勢
那你可能已經很久了
過兩三個禮拜了
已經疊很多了
所以我們在第一個訊號看到這個
叫調人線
如果長你就辦法
沒有什麼理由要賣
可是你一看它不長
好 我們來看另外一檔
還有一種情形
也是叫上漲
但是它的趨勢是空頭的反彈
空頭反彈我們在
在操作上是準備做空
對不對 因為你是空頭
反彈完了 如果你再疊我就要做空
所以當空頭反彈
在上面你看到了一個掉人蟹
大概這個就告訴你反彈結束了
你第二天就可以準備做空了
反而空頭的反彈出現掉
你現在不要開心喔
不代表買盤
代表要再往下了
當然 當然
這做空啊
因為我們做股票
一直跟大家講
你先確認空頭嘛
趨勢是空 你只能做空嘛
對不對
你不要去做其他的
這個做多
你看這一反彈
是不是就有一個
剛才的
上影線
壁垒針
那你第二天
你又可以空啊
對不對
所以我們剛才
我們這兩根K線
如果你用在空頭裡面
反彈的高檔就是準備做空的
我講準備就是你當天還不能空
要看隔天
對 萬一他第二天再漲了
那你空的就被尬到了
所以你看隔天
隔天如果一疊他就會疊
隔天一疊他就會疊
所以你看只要你可以現在會用
機會很多嘛
在多頭你可以停歷
在空頭你可以做空
你看到這個就準備第二天去空
所以這個 因為什麼
因為這也叫高檔
這叫反彈的高檔
因為我已經彈一天 兩天 三天
這是我第四天
你第四天就看到有人盤中在殺
殺下來
那如果再殺呢
那當然他就會跌
所以我們把趨勢套上去
朱老師聽到現在啊
我們過去會一直以為
留下長的 下影線是好
但看來只要位置錯了
就都不好對不對
在高檔都不好
不管你留著上影線下影線
都不好
就是你上漲的上面
所以剛剛那些報導要重寫了
那如果你是
如果你是下來的下面
那如果空頭就會反彈
你要回補了
對不對
好
有的掉人線是脾氣
那我們也一樣
掉人線是不是第二天
就真的一定要走
如果在高檔也不一定
多頭上漲出現超長的下影線
第二天就出現怎麼樣
紅K了
紅K上漲我們還可以再看一下
再看一下
因為你第二天是往上的
看來也是有人接走是不是
如果你這個紅K又把昨天這根
掉人線給突破了
就最高點過了
那你就確認多頭繼續
你就續保
總之隔天都要有突破對不對
所以一樣的不管你是碧雷珍
不管你是這個
掉人線
這一掌有年老師在我們節目有推
還不錯還不錯
現在還很強
是很強推的時候是剛剛才被動
好我們來看這個地方多頭確認
大家看有大量
這個很確
然後紅K進場守一個停損
因為他也沒疊對不對
好那你看這裡是不是有個壁壘爭
那第二天就要注意
如果他要是
因為我們做短線守武軍
第二天要疊破武軍
那你的短線是不是要先走
因為他轉弱了
沒有紅K上來了
這裡又來了一個壁壘爭
那第二天是紅的
我們剛剛有講
壁雷針的第二天紅的 你不要罵
但他還沒有辦法確認
這個才確認 過高了
過了壁雷針的高點
這個地方要繼續走
他繼續走
那這你是不是又出了壁雷針
第二天出一個什麼 掉人線
像這樣一下壁雷針一下掉人線
有沒有特別的含義
一樣 就是後面只能長不能疊
一樣 第三天只能長不能疊
因為你這個壁雷針第二天不能疊
那你這個掉人線
第二天也是不能跌
這兩個如果一跌
那你從這你大概也可以短線獲利
那我們這個調人線第二天是不是過高了
那當然壁雷震也過高
所以他又一天兩天三天
你又有三天了
所以如果你看得懂這些變化
當然這是很短線的
很超級短線的
趨勢是另外趨勢嗎
比如說從這到這
如果你抱趨勢
那就不要去看K線變化
什麼叫趨勢
就是它還是頭頭高啊
那我就一直抱吧
你五軍都沒有破嘛
我就一直抱吧 守五軍就好了
對 那我們現在講的是短線的轉折
所以大家分清楚
你在進場的時候你要做轉折
你要看到轉折要有一些
這個變化你要不要去變
你要不要買了 你要自己決定
至少告訴你明天如果它
疊的話它就會疊
那你要不要賣
所以我一直講
操作每個人都不一樣
每個人的方法不同
好 相信經過這一集
什麼是壁壘爭 什麼是吊人線
不要再傻傻覺得壁壘爭就是
不好 吊人線就一定代表好
今天全部解析給你聽
並不是如此
當然剛剛我相信大家聽了
都一定會有一個疑問
朱老師每次都說高檔高檔
長三根不追我知道啦
可是我有的股票
高檔可能長20%是高檔
股票漲一倍是高檔的
股票漲三百趴是高檔
高檔怎麼分
這個就要進入我們的榮耀班囉
然後班會把壁壘爭再加上一個指標
來教你什麼樣叫做真正的高檔
因為現在萬七了
如果要逃命的話
一定要學會指標的綜合運用喔
好今天非常謝謝朱老師
趙懷上了一課了耶
因為趙懷以前也常在那邊寫文章
就會想說你像影線啊
就是有支撐啊
上影線就不好
但是今天已經教你的
不是這樣判斷喔
還是跟股票的高低的位置有關係
所以相信這兩個名詞
大家今天上完這房子
應該是非常的清楚
而且是阿總的運用囉
希望大家能夠在標股再見等
學到更多的知識喔
那我們下次再見了
掰掰